in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Andrew
and Justine are with us hi how are you
hey we've got so much to tell you
I can't wait to hear it all where are
you guys from Philadelphia Pennsylvania
awesome welcome to Nashville yeah I'm
guessing you're here to do a debt-free
scream yes sir how much have you paid
off $45,000 very cool
and how long did that take 15 months
very good
making what kind of range of income
during that time started about 160 now
about 185 way to go what do you guys do
for a living I'm a proud occupational
therapist at Shriners Hospital for
Children in Philadelphia you ought to be
and I'm a consultant for companies that
run large construction projects very
cool good good excellent career is very
cool what kind of debt was the forty
five thousand well it was mostly our
combined student loans but there was
also a brand-new car in their brand new
car how much how much of the forty five
was the car it was about fifteen okay
thirty on stealing on the student loans
okay all right and so what happened 15
months ago so when we graduated college
we had about a hundred thousand dollars
a day and we always knew that we wanted
to pay off her debt and it was a
priority in our lives what we really
struggled with was the hell and as two
young professionals with good advancing
careers we thought the answer was to
make more money yeah so that's really
what we were concentrating on that and
we were only considering the income and
not the outgo and
you know late 2014 I got a good raise at
work and we've lived with that for a
couple months and had no more money to
show for it
yeah we were not making progress it just
was all going out Laurette no way
exactly and we were just tired of
working that hard and not making any
progress they can fire to being sick and
tired
so no I go online and start doing some
searches and luckily I found your
website and I was on board as soon as
soon as I read it very cool and then
well the implication there is that I was
not
but I was selling here it so you know
andrew has always been the financial guy
the numbers guy in a relationship which
I love him for immensely and personal
finances made me feel completely
overwhelmed out of control I really felt
like the way I'm elated
completely intimidated and the way I was
measuring my financial health was just
to sort of benchmark myself with those
around me you know if I was sort of
doing what those around me were doing I
must be doing ok I must be being an
adult and I'm I'm gonna be ok but it
took a little growing up to sort of
realize that you know you don't figure
out if you're sick by putting the
thermometer in somebody else's a year
you've got it you got it yourself a
little more closely and so initially
when Andrew brought up kind of a
zero-based budget and the Dave Ramsey
plan I thought it seems a little
excessive but it did not take long of
you know participating in the process
and the monthly budget meetings to
really see that traction and get that
snowball going and it did not take very
long to get me on board so certainly I
got that first budget night the first
time you sit down your palms happy swell
I mean the probably the first three
there were some serious serious
arguments was one of them tell us all
what was one of the arguments around
here I think yeah so I think initially
we started budgeting right after we got
married three years ago and our initial
budgets were not zero base and that was
where a lot of the issues were because
you know I'm the numbers guy and I had
ideals in my head of what we should be
able to do so the other budgets were
about you telling Justine what to do but
when we started doing the zero base
budget there was definitely a change in
the way we budget and we the way we
communicated about it and that was the
key to success once we started doing
that it was really about small
refinements and not argument yeah and I
have to say I'm I mean I'm totally on
board now I mean it was my idea that we
start semi monthly meetings we meet
twice a month because I love that
feeling of control now that I have over
the money and telling my dollars what to
do and so we get to the mid month and I
am able to feel that control again and
say hey we've still got some takeout
dollars left or
you know this and that and it's
empowering to feel that way yeah you
have this it's exactly it's in control
and it's empowering those are the exact
words that's very very good
and that that's the dichotomy I remember
I mean I remember it like it was
yesterday I can see the kitchen table it
was 30 years ago and I can see Sharon
you know with her fists balled up and
mad and arguing about the food budget I
can't believe with three with two kids
at that time that she was going to spend
that much on food I couldn't believe it
yeah yeah I was challenging her on it
she gets me got mad I got mad I mean it
was a fight and that was our first
budget meeting and it didn't go well
well at all but it had you know what's
funny is it has to do with being afraid
that your vote is not going to count and
it has to do with being intimidated and
mix in there for me anyway and for
Sharon I don't put this on you guys but
a little bit of shame and a little bit
of guilt that I don't know what I'm
doing and I feel out of control and so
I've kind of got a bow up you know I
think for coming from such sort of a and
I'll say it about myself an ignorant
place myself in terms of my financial
literacy you know what you're speaking
to being able to Institute the baby
steps and then get a greater picture of
where our funds were going to really
help them through the budgeting process
because I was able to kind of expand my
view to the bigger picture and it took a
few months of budgeting and seeing the
progress we were making to even take a
step back and say whoa like we're gonna
have money to retire with this is our
whole lives we're talking about work
this is really gonna work and that's a
really exciting feeling and it feels
good to be on a her financial her
financial literacy has improved so much
over the last 15 months I mean last
month she came to me with her mutual
funds in her 403b
and said these are the ones I want to
pick I think he was afraid I had a
secret twin sister he was like what did
you do with my wife yeah when you come
in and start telling mr. nerd how it's
gonna go down that's awesome
very cool well that's you know that and
that's where you should be you're
empowered and then you both have an
intelligent wise vote on how our
households going to be run where we're
going with our money our treasures where
our heart is
and where we go from there so you guys
did all of this from the website or what
daily listening to the podcast I booked
my makeover and thread tyrant retire
inspired to it but I've got a whole lot
of a whole lot of podcasts on my phone
right now a lot of commutes listening to
Dave Ramsey yeah we're honored we're
honored you guys are incredible so what
would you tell people that the biggest
key is obviously the zero-based budget
played a big part for you guys what else
that was huge and for me just kind of
the getting focused on on what I needed
to do to get there you know the the
simple math seemed so intimidating and I
think you just really have to get sick
and tired of being sick and tired
harness that focus and pull in all the
in comings and all the outgoings and
it's it's really simple arithmetic when
it comes down to it so good it doesn't
have to be so scary you just kind of
need to harness that motivation and
focus and go for it do you have a trick
that you would I think just the
communication just sitting down and
doing it and doing it together as a team
that's when we really started to have
success so we did together you started
off this thing wrong Andrew with how you
were communicating with her absolutely
what would you say the guys are too Towe
spouses that are on board and they're
trying to get there trying to get the
reluctant spouse to do this with them
that you did wrong and then what did you
do right that caused this to this
communication actually happened so I
stopped focusing on the immediate step
of let's spend less money and I started
talking about what we can do together as
a team and what we want to do in our
future and how these steps will get us
there right it's not about the mechanics
it's about the vision at the end and how
we're going to get there do it together
start talking about why we're doing
exactly not just what we're doing yeah
the Y's bigger than the what right I
mean I'm an engineer so I love you love
you love the tactical yeah
so yeah we can tell so Justine did you
feel that did you feel that from him oh
yeah and and I think I could definitely
feel the shift too I mean whenever
there's a shift in communication - I
understand where you are on this let's
get on the same page let's go somewhere
together I think you can't help but feel
that and I appreciate that well done oh
here we are
$45,000 paid off in 15 months Andrew and
Justine count it down let's hear a debt
free scream 3 2 1 we're debt-free
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that your
bro-friends think you've lost your mind